Sall ragnaroks just got its first
glorious trailer and it's packed with
teasers for the upcoming third Thor
movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
UPK movie lovers it's Chan here and in
this video I'm breaking down the new
school Ragnarok trailer for Easter eggs
and other hidden details you might have
missed so of course the speculation and
potential spoilers ahead for Thor
Ragnarok let's start with our awesome
shot of sorcerer and his hammer at
Heller
notice how the sequence is happening on
earth and just there next to Thor in the
alley
it looks like Loki this links back to
the mid credit scene as the Doctor
Strange movie where Thor visits strange
in his sanctum sanctorum and explains
that he needs to bring Loki to New York
to look for their father Odin who's gone
missing now back to this trailer hello
of course destroys Thor's hammer
crushing it into small pieces it's
interesting that sort of hammer gets
destroyed because we're still waiting to
find out where that final Infinity stone
the soul stone is hidden and one theory
is that it could be hidden inside Thor's
hammer so is it possible that Heller did
this to get the missing stone an
alternate soulstone theory states that
it's contained in Heimdall's armor and
if you notice in this scene from the
trailer he's not wearing his usual armor
so I also wonder whether this has
anything to do with the soul stone okay
back to Heller and this awesome shot of
her with their full head gear looks
stunning me like it's taken straight
from the comic books and her at the
light gear also appears in another shot
later when she's battling the war
goddesses known as a Valkyrie or who are
mounted on their winged horses in what
could be a flashback scene notice a blue
cape which Valkyrie often has in the
comics and as a Valkyrie or attack
Heller the goddess of death launches her
sword and the next shot is a Valkyrie
falling together with other defeated
warriors in the distance
Valkyries defeat is presumably the
reason why we find her working for the
Grandmaster later in the trailer rather
than living on Asgard by the way like
the collector from guardians of the
galaxy the Grandmaster is one of the
elders of the universe and they both
have a similar look including markings
on their lip and chin and given it to
game living Grandmaster who's presiding
over the gladiator battles in the movie
it looks like you're taking on a similar
role in this story to the red king who
ruled the planet sakaar
in the Planet Hulk storyline in the
comics which I'll talk more about
shortly curiously in the comics at one
time the Grandmaster had the mind gem
now in the MCU
actually possessed by vision so it's
also possible that in the movie the
Grandmaster might be the one with a
final Infinity stone aka the soul stone
back on as God we see a sweeping view of
the city complete with the Rainbow
Bridge aka the Bifrost which allows
travel between the nine realms and
Haller is there in front of an army of
Asgardian warriors without her headdress
and pulled out her sword assuring the
words as God is dead just before a huge
explosion sweeps through the city which
interestingly passes over a very
particular tree this tree looks like a
representation of the symbolic in
crystal tree which has already appeared
in two previous Marvel movies the first
time it appeared was in the first
Captain America movie where it was
carved into the wall where Red Skull
discovered the tesseract its second
appearance was when Thor sketched the
tree as a way to explain the nine realms
to Jane Foster the Yggdrasil tree in
both the movies and the comics connects
all the nine realms and the destruction
the tree by Heller symbolizes the extent
of the devastation she's unleashed on
Asgard by the way the word Ragnarok
means the series of events in Norse
mythology that foretell the doom of the
gods so now we've introduced the main
villain hella let's step back to the
beginning of the trailer where Thor is
being dropped into a huge fiery cavern a
sword angles ur notice these faces
lighting up with one of them also
opening its mouth slightly these could
be either fire demons which in the
comics originate from the realm of
Muspelheim with the enormous and hugely
powerful demon Surtur rules alternately
the faces could be sold the dead in
Heller's domain hel the faces appear to
be kind of stacked in mounds one on top
of the other which seems to indicate
that these could be tormented souls that
hella has acquired however footage shown
at San Diego comic-con revealed a scene
of the Hulk getting ready to fight Sirte
meaning the Hulk might be about to burst
in and save so here either way I can't
wait to find out the other location we
get a really good look at is the planets
icon if you look up at the sky you can
see all these portals which basically
wormholes that connect to various parts
of the universe which is how Saul got
them and the portals are also a way for
the rest of the universe to dump their
trash on sakaar in the comics Sarkar is
the location where the Planet Hulk
storyline takes place and it's inherited
by all kinds of dodgy characters which
we get to see in the trailer so we know
that some elements of Planet Hulk are
being used in the movie
Hulk's having to fight as a gladiator on
soccer in the comics he ends up there
after he sent into space for being too
dangerous however quite why and how he
ended up there in the MCU isn't clear
just yet in Ragnarok we're going to
teeth all have to fight without his
mighty hammer and the last time Thor had
to face Hulk without his hammer in the
first Avengers movie things didn't
exactly go brilliantly foresaw not only
has he been painted here but he's also
had his hair cut short the arena this
short head look tipped his hat to the
unworthy saw comics where the god of
thunder also deals with the consequences
of losing the ability to wield his
hammer but at least Thor has got himself
a cool lurking new helmet and the last
time we saw him with a helmet was in the
first Thor movie
Thor's replacement weapon which is a
kind of Club could be a nod to the
golden mace weapon wielded by hercules
in the comics
I thought the Hulk's gladiator look was
just fantastic including much of his
Planet Hulk look from the comics it is
also a great nod to Incredible Hulk
comic books TV and movie titles we've
introduced as The Incredible just before
he Hulk smashes his way into the arena
that line that source us about Hulk's
being a friend from work was just
brilliant - and reminded me that even
when the two have worked together for
example during the Battle of New York in
The Avengers movie that didn't stop the
Hulk giving saw one of his trademark
side punches but the tone of this scene
also made me think of those hilarious
Thor mockumentary is where saws friend
Daryl tells the Asgardian God that he
should get a job
- which Thor replies that he already has
one saving the planet in fact although
Thor Ragnarok isn't a full-on comedy
director Taika Waititi has said he
wanted to make use of Chris Hemsworth
and Mark Ruffalo comedic chops in what
becomes a kind of road movie and in the
gladiator arena we see the grandmasters
booth which includes some very
interesting characters including what
could be a celestial plus Loki is there
- Celestials have already shown up in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
guardians of the galaxy each on the
searcher was a celestial who destroyed a
planet with the Power Stone and the
mining colony nowhere was as Gamora
explained in that movie the severed head
of an ancient celestial being
Ragnarok director title ytt also teased
another celestial helmet on his
Instagram and has been speculation that
this helmet belongs to the Celestials he
around the tester there are the testers
after the Infinity Gauntlet storyline in
the comics so to ragnerok maybe about to
give the Celestials a more important
role in the MCU going forward by the way
it looks like there's a cameo here also
by actress Rachel House who is in
director title whitey T's previous movie
hunt for the world people you might also
her know recently as a voice of Grandma
taller in Disney's Moana and title ytt
also snuck in a hunt for the world of
people Easter Egg via this graffiti
behind Thor which reads skirts life
skirts life is a slang phrase
protagonists Ricky Baker uses to talk
about being gangster and the phrase has
a similar meaning to Sir Clive and
directed white et has also talked about
how influential the work of the
legendary comic book artist and writer
Jack Kirby has been on the look of
Ragnarok and we can see various visual
our largest occur be in the trailer for
example the wall behind the Grandmaster
is literally taken straight from the
design on a Power Core in the century
Sinister Fantastic Four comic the
trailer also introduces us to this guy
scourge aka the executioner who's played
by Karl Urban and the scene looks like
it's been taken straight from saw issue
3 6 2 in which scourge makes a noble
sacrifice by defending the bridge as
hell protecting school and a group who
are trying to get out of them Thor's
vision in Avengers age of Ultron had
Heimdall accusing source saying to him
they see you leading us to hell so could
thor ragnarok involved thor having to
get the Asgardians out of hell and mike
scourge sacrifice himself in a similar
way to the comics now it's unclear
whether this scene involving Loki has
anything to do with a bridge out of hell
that scourge is defending behind Loki is
a mass of people who look to be trying
to break through while Loki is a cool
looking double dagger flip by the way in
the comics goddess of death Heller is
actually Loki's daughter so it'll be
interesting to see if there's any
relation between them in the movie and
this is an interesting scene with a
spacecraft which looks to be positioning
itself to shoot through that portal
which is curiously shaped and colored
like an eye perhaps it's school Hulk
from Valkyrie leaving Sarkar but what is
intriguing is that the colours of the
craft are the same as the colours of
Captain Marvel costumes and of course
one of Captain Marvel skills is her
expertise as a pilot it might not be
Marvel herself of course but could this
be an awesome little tease for her movie
music wise the trailer features the
awesome Led Zeppelin track immigrant
song
lyrics for which appropriately enough
include the words hammer of the gods and
references to Norse mythology so guys
what did you think of the sword Ragnarok
trailer whether any other details you
spotted and do you think we'll get an
infinity stone reveal in the movie I'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate your likes and shares
and while you're here check out some of
my other trailer breakdowns and Marvel
videos by tapping or clicking here
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers